good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways that you
can stay organized and productive number
three is my personal favorite and make
sure to stick around other to the end
for my thoughts on the matter - a lot of
people ask how do you organize your life
when you have so much to do in so little
time
it seems to be chaotic and the phone is
ringing it people are calling and
unexpected emergencies crop up and
things that you expected to happen don't
happen and things that you that do
happen take much longer than you thought
it cost much more and so on well I say
join the human race the fact is that
that in our world today there's so much
good stuff going on that we are eager to
take a piece of everything we're
constantly raising our hand if you like
and say I'll do that and I'll do this
I'll get into that and I'll add that to
my schedule and so on so as I mentioned
earlier the starting point of getting
your life under control is to sit down
and think about two things who you
really are which means what are your
natural talents and abilities what do
you enjoy what do you like doing if you
could wave a magic wand if you were
financially independent what you do want
to do with your life based on your own
talents and abilities another question
we ask is if you could work at any job
or in any industry or in any position or
in any part of the country what would
they be and think think them through at
Stanford University they teach and
exercise in the creative thinking part
of the business faculty it's called the
2010 exercise and that's imagine that
you have 20 million dollars cash in the
bank just for fun and inheritance you
want a lottery but simultaneously you
have an incurable illness and you only
have ten years left to live if you have
twenty million dollars in the bank and
ten years left to live what choices and
decisions would you make for your life
and that begins to clarify things you
start to become clear well if I had that
money and only a limited time there are
certain things I would want to do and
certain things that would not be that
important the second goal area is what
do you really really want from your
life if you had no limitations if you
had all the money in all the time and
all the talents and all the abilities if
you could do or be or have anything what
would you really want in your life and
write them down and then what I
encourage people to do is make a list of
ten things ten goals that you like to
accomplish in the next year or so and
ask this question if I could only
accomplish one goal on this list which
one goal would have the greatest
positive impact on my life if you could
only accomplish one goal in life which
one goal would have the greatest
positive impact on your life now for
most people especially when you're
maturing in your career when you're
growing up the biggest goal is money if
you had money then you could buy a house
home car family lifestyle and so on so
that's quite normal for other people it
may be a health goal for business owners
may be a business goal for people with
relationship problems may be a
relationship goal but ask yourself if
you could achieve one goal or resolve
one problem and remember a problem
unsolved is merely a goal unachieved
which one would it be and write that
down and make that that the major a
definite purpose of your life make it
the central organizing principle of your
life now both gang funds good - had a
wonderful observation about life he
basically said that everything counts
everything that we do helps our hurts
everything adds up or takes away so once
you have a very clear goal then just
simply ask yourself based on what I
really really want for my life what's
most important to me is what I'm about
to do helping or hurting is it going to
move me toward my goal or move me away
and if it doesn't move you toward what
is most important to you then it's a
very good candidate to be a delegated
outsourced downsized or even eliminated
in the process of re-engineering in
business the whole process of
re-engineering is based on what is
called process simplification and the
way that you simplify a process is you
stop doing things you eliminate low
value tasks to free up more time for the
things that are most important to you
you keep going through your life and
saying what are the things that I could
get rid of but I could stop doing all
together that I could delegate to
someone else or that I could combine to
do all together you keep thinking how
can I simplify my life how can I
re-engineer my life
so it's simpler and more streamlined and
then you concentrate more and more time
doing fewer and fewer things which give
you greater and greater results
financial and satisfaction emotional in
your life
so no matter how late at night you go
before you wrap up just take four
minutes and really think through
everything that you have to get done for
the next day so here's how I usually do
it first thing I do is I open up my
calendar and I take a look at all the
appointments that I have for the next
day and the time that those appointments
will take like this one o'clock I got a
team call that last 30 minutes 3:30 I
have a marietv script review that'll
take about an hour and then I have a
6:30 spin class then I write down all
the projects and the tasks that I need
to get done and I give myself a little
bit of an estimate about how long I
think each project or task will take of
course these are estimates sometimes I
get things done faster and sometimes
they take longer but at least I get
myself a baseline to work off of 9:00 to
10:30 a.m. I'm going to write a first
draft of a sales video script I'm going
to give myself about 90 minutes then
from 11:30 to 12:30 I'm going to review
my social media schedule give myself an
hour for that and from 2:30 to 3:00 I'll
do a little email clear out and finally
I make a new little section at the
bottom of my notepad with personal
things that I need to handle for that
day for example get nanny a birthday
card and mail it that'll take me about
30 minutes order more kuma food all of
10 minutes and book a haircut for the
next month takes me about five minutes
boom that is it super simple so when I
do this it informs exactly when I need
to be at my desk and working which tells
me when I need to wake up to have enough
time to do my little morning routine and
get everything done without feeling
rushed or stressed the worst thing you
can do is wake up in the morning and go
straight to your computer and open up
email and then all of a sudden you're
pretending to work all day and at the
end the day nothing important ever got
done nobody's perfect and of course not
every day goes as planned but this
system gives you the best chance
possible and making sure that your most
important projects get done especially
if you have an inconsistent schedule
almost everything you do from the time
you get up in the morning is habit so
start to think about yourselves what
would be the best habits to
have now I have written a book called
million dollar habits it has twelve
chapters twelve critical areas of life
and in each chapter this twenty or
thirty habits so let me give you some of
the best number one develop the habit of
daily goal setting and goal orientation
what does this mean this means when you
go to sleep at night think about your
goals for the coming day make a list for
each day of all the goals the little
goals you're going to accomplish that
day keep a journal and write down your
goals on a regular basis when you're
driving through the day think about your
goals when you're talking to other
people think about your goals you see
you do become what you think about most
of the time you do achieve what you
think about most of the time so all
successful people and all wealthy people
think about their goals most of the time
second of all be results oriented
now results-oriented people are always
thinking of the most important things
that they can do right now to achieve
their most important results successful
people make a list of everything they
have to do and before they start working
they set priorities on the list here's a
great way to become result-oriented
actually it's life-changing
ask yourself once you have your list for
the day if I could only do one thing on
this list before I was called out of
town for a month what one activity what
I want to be sure to get completed and
put a circle around that and start on
that activity immediately first thing
and then discipline yourself to work
non-stop until you complete that one
activity this simple technique has taken
people from rags to riches
all over the world for at least a
hundred years make your most important
tasks and start on it immediately and
then discipline yourself to stay with it
until it's complete another habit that
you can establish is to become people
oriented recognize that everything that
you achieve in life is going to be with
the help or support or cooperation of
other people so always think what is it
that other people want and need from me
how can I help other people so they'll
want to help me back if you're in sales
drop sales people think about their
customers all the time they think about
who their customers
are and what their customers want and
how they can help them the most and how
they can help them even more today in
their relationships successful people
are very focused on the most important
people in their worlds both personal and
in business another habit you can have
is to stay health oriented think about
your health most of the time think about
eating less food and better food think
about daily exercise thinking about
getting lots of rest
remember to be successful in our
competitive world you need a lot of
energy to have a lot of energy you've
got a good foods get lots of rest and
exercise all the time one of the most
important habits is that of character
and honesty is always tell the truth no
matter what the price and the final
characteristic the final habit is that
of self-discipline and I have written
and spoken upon this for years and years
and years but self-discipline seems to
be the foundation habit that makes
everything else possible and the best
definition of self-discipline is that
self-discipline is the ability to make
yourself do what you should do when you
should do it
whether you feel like it or not you see
anybody can do it if they feel like it
it's when you don't feel like it and you
do it anyway that you eventually develop
the self-discipline that makes
everything else possible all ideas don't
work unless you do the work that some of
the best work you can do is getting
really good at creating a one page plan
have your big five the five things that
need to happen this year for this to be
your best year yet on a one-page plan
your top five values put them on that
same plan your top five sub goals
sequence into each quarter of this year
on that one page plan and every morning
all your competition or the rest of the
world is asleep get up at 5:00 a.m. I'll
teach you how to do that in future
videos but look at your one page plan to
spend 20 minutes on that so it becomes a
brain tattoo a burning obsession so what
L lights you with inspiration so you
vote in the world and you understand
clarity is power and you so intimately
know what has to happen during this day
this week this month this quarter this
year to get you closer to your mountain
top because the ordinary though the
hours that ordinary people waste
extraordinary people do because they're
not bored like most people most people
need to medicate themselves with too
much TV
too much Facebook too much video too
much chitchat too much busyness because
they don't know their goals because they
don't have a one-page plan because they
don't have a one-page schedule I mean
I've got my schedule for every 7 days
almost everything I need to do goes on
it and you might say Robin well that's a
very rigid way to live no it's a very
free way to live because then I have the
power to live life on my own terms I
feel inspired I'm not wasting each day
I'm leveraging each day number 4 use a
planner or a diary just as useful as
using a calendar but I find that this
one is a bit more specific especially if
you have specific appointments or
specific things that you have to do on a
daily basis it does help just shutting
them down in your diary as well as your
calendar and you can refer to it when
you're on the go as well not just in a
place in your house that you can
actually look at it when you're on your
way to work when you're at school or
just before a meeting or maybe you just
want to refer to it just any time during
the day so it is worth having a planner
or a diary the reason so many people
aren't productive throughout the day is
not only because they don't have their
purpose and their psychology in the
physiology supporting them but also
because they're going through the day in
an ignorant way you know they're going
through the day focus solely on
responding to everybody else's
emergencies you know here's what most
people do they wake up they get ready
for the day they go through the they go
to work they're not really thinking
about anything yet they're just kind of
going through the motions they get to
work and what do they do
they open up their email INBOX which is
the worst thing you could ever do to be
productive your inbox is a nice
organizing system of other people's
agendas that's what an inbox really is
it's a nice organizing system other
every email and there are someone
needing something from you or pulling
from you that's what most of them are
isn't it true and so what most people do
is they open up
in box and they start responding to
other people's and emergencies or they
start recently to start looking through
all their emails to see well what am I
supposed to do today or what's the
biggest fire I have to fight today in
other words they're living their life in
reaction versus living their life in
intention in intelligence in direction
they're not focused on what to do
throughout the day they're just saying
well I'll do this because that's what
popped up today you know so for
personally I never even check email
until 10 a.m.
when I get up and I'm looking at
everything I'm sit down and I strategize
my day before I ever even think about
checking my email and then I might only
check my email once or twice a day
because I set up all other systems to
support my ability to be productive
because in your life I'm guessing that
you're only really making money if
you're producing and in my my industry I
live in the experts industry that's the
sort of the self-help spirituality
business growth world where we offer
advice to other people about how they
can improve their life or build their
business that's the expert industry in
the expert industry most people are
really struggling to be productive
because we're creatives right we have so
many great ideas and so many great
intentions throughout the day and we
have so many ideas we can never actually
accomplish them
maybe you're the same maybe at base
you're really a creator and you have all
these ideas of so many things you want
to do but you've never really been able
to organize them and get them done
because you haven't set up systems to
support your levels of productivity
let's start with the beginning of your
day I'm going to just jump into one
little thing that I do at the beginning
the day it's not the very beginning but
I think it will help you and it's a way
of organizing my day and I call this one
page productivity it's just a simple
sheet of paper that I have that I fill
in when the morning after I've gone out
I've exercise that's a piece of my
morning activity is mastering my
physiology so I can become a high
performer starts with me drinking lots
of water in the morning eating the right
things going for a little quick run or
workout or even just a brisk walk to
energize my body in my mind so that can
be creative and think and when I get
back to my office and it's time to
actually work I do this one-page product
and this one-page productivity sheet
helps me really think through what I
need to do throughout the day so here's
the three elements of this and by the
way below this video you can download
this sheet and you can use it on your
daily life let me walk you through how
to use it basically there's three
elements of the one-page productivity
the first element is major projects
these major projects usually if any
given person probably has oh I don't
know you know like three big buckets of
projects that they're working on so I
might be working on you know writing a
new book I might be working on doing a
new seminar I might be working on you
know reinvigorating my online marketing
those are big big these are big bucket
projects that aren't necessarily they're
not the priorities for the day these are
the big vision these connect me to the
what are the big things I'm doing in any
given person if they're well organized
they're probably only working on three
maybe five main projects so I want you
to do when you start out in the morning
it to keep you big thinking big and
thinking outside of just the day to
focus is you know and and the high
performance Academy we've already talked
about purpose so we're already engaged
there okay this is just a little snippet
I want you think about the big picture
of your projects and I want you to think
about what are the five things that you
would have to do to move these projects
forward this is not five things that you
need to move them forward today
that's your priorities your projects are
just in general what are the big things
that you need to do the big five things
you would have to do so for example if
online marketing is one of my big
projects and Riaan regret one of the
things I might have to do is learn to
code a webpage right or learn to design
a webpage now that's a project it
doesn't mean that today I'm going to
learn how to do it it just means in
general that's one of the things that
we'll have to do so these are one of the
five big things you would have to do to
actually make that project come into
fruition what would you have to learn
what would you have to go out and master
what would you have to who would you
have to contact one of the things you
would have to do for your big projects
next is people category in this people
category I want you to think of two
things
in the people category the people
category is really important for high
performers because high performers
really get ahead not just because of who
they know but how they're engaging who
they know right what they're asking for
what they're doing so the people
category that I want you think of each
morning on this one page productivity is
two categories one I want you to sit
down and think of who do you need to
reach out to today who do you need to
reach out to so if I want to learn
coding as an example in general I might
want to schedule some time with a code
or web designer so I'm like I'm gonna
have to reach out to a coder or web
designer today and this is important
because most people when they open up
their inbox they just start replying to
all these things when I open my inbox
the first thing I do is I send out these
emails people I need to reach out to
it's the first thing that I do when I
open my inbox as an example very first
thing is send out all the emails of
people I need to reach out to the second
category here is the people that you are
waiting on right given any person's real
schedule you're waiting on somebody to
give you some information or a decision
to move forward in your day isn't it
true you're waiting on something from
some body so that you can move forward
and most people they just sit there and
they wait for the email to pop up they
they hope that it's going to come they
don't do anything about it second thing
I do when I open my inbox after I reach
out to the people I reach out to the
people who I'm waiting on and I say
something specific to them so let me
give you an example how this actually
might operationalize in the day when I
open my inbox I'll look in my emails for
these people first and foremost it's the
first thing I'll do after I send out the
ones I need to reach out to
strategically I'll say Who am I waiting
on a look at and I'll open up their
inbox or open up their email to see if I
got what I needed if I didn't I send an
email right back to them to make sure I
get what I need as fast as possible so
yes there's an element of you hounding
people to become productive you know
most people just sitting around waiting
for other people to help their dreams
come true for me I'm chasing people down
right you know I want four high
performers there's a level of impatience
there you know if you want to come a
high performer you've got to have this
level of
patience that says I need to accomplish
as I need to do this let's go let's go
let's go
you need to be on a faster path in life
not stressed out more but more focused
on achieving what you need to do to
become happy to become successful not
just because someday that's going to
happen for you but in the moment in the
moment being a happy and successful so
that you can be happy and successful
hope that makes sense also that's the
people category then the next category
is the priority category okay your
priority category is what are the 10
things that you've got accomplished
today these are the 10 must do items
this is sort of like your to-do list but
it's ranked in order of most importance
so very simple right because to-do lists
are great I'm all for them all I'm all
for day planners because it helps you
achieve some of these things but at the
end of the day you got to think about
okay what are my real priorities today
and here's what I'll often do depending
on how big these are and how important
they are when I get to my when I've
written all these out here's how my day
works here's what the order of things
that I'll achieve they're up a day first
I'll do whatever it takes to achieve
these priorities whether it is sending
an email or whether it is you know
running an errand or whether it's
calling somebody these priorities in my
day happen first often before I even
open my inbox or if I have to open my
inbox I'll wait but priorities first
accomplish these first no matter what
these get done first before I respond to
anybody else's emergency or go through
all my inbox these first then I move up
second I'll go okay Who am I waiting on
and who do I need to reach out to the
people category I'll do that no often
this will take most of the entire day
and then I'll say if there's any given
time left in the day I'll focus back on
the bigger projects thinking about what
it's going to take to accomplish them
for me being organized and productive is
all about having a schedule that best
fits my needs and what I'm going through
so I live and die by my Google Calendar
and every day of the week I have
assigned to different things that I'm
working on so Monday is Mike
ten day it's where I'm spending good
chunks of time reviewing the videos that
need to go up on the YouTube channel
giving my feedback improvements where we
need to make changes and it's also my
book day so if we need to make changes
to the website write more copy from the
book anything about the book I take care
of that on Monday Tuesday's all about my
mentorship day and so I'll watch videos
in the morning to help me be a better
mentor so be mentoring the people on my
team I'll be mentoring Alex from China
dance salsa who I'm trying to grow it to
be an even bigger leader than he is now
and I also take time I leave at 2:45 to
go pick up Hayden and I spend the rest
of the day and evening mentoring him as
well and with the intent of trying to be
a good role model and mentor to him and
not just play together and so I turned
to Z for mentorship day Wednesday is my
video production day recording day I'm
in you know now my home studio or the
Toronto de and salsa recording videos
for you guys for the YouTube channel
Thursday is my public-facing day doing
interviews media radio meetings phone
calls hangouts as always on the Thursday
and Friday is my CEO day that I split
between my business and Toronto dance
salsa and anytime that I find that my
schedules out of whack that I'm not able
to get something done that I really need
to get done or you know if I have to
work late into the night because there's
this new project that popped up that
doesn't fit into my current schedule if
that happens for too many days or to
consistently that I need to change up my
schedule so for example when I took over
Toronto dance salsa I needed to make
time for it wouldn't fit into my already
packed schedule so I had to adjust and
take away other things that one is high
priority and focus more on Toronto than
salsa so to resume spending time with
Alex fry and spending time doing CEO
work for Toronto and salsa and so I
think in your life if you figure out
what are the key areas that you need to
focus on in both business and life like
what are the main things that have to
get done consistently on a weekly basis
and then assign time in your calendar to
deal with those things I find that helps
me stay organized it helps you stay
energized else we know that the things
that I need to get done are going to get
done and I've lived by my Google
Calendar for years and probably will
continue to do so because at least for
me I find it highly effective so I'd
love to know what you guys think of this
video which of the clips meant the most
to you how are you going to apply to
your schedule in your life I love
to know how you stay organized and how
you stay prepared and how you stay
motivated leave it in the comments below
and I will join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to Lou
eat your hand from last minute training
Louis bought two copies of my book thank
you so much Lou it really means a lot to
me for those of you watching if you want
a chance at a shadow in their future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and then email in your receipt so
we can keep track thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon